so my name is Lila I am a software
engineer at stripe and if you're
unfamiliar with what stripe does stripes
a technology company or set of tools
that helps you build and run an internet
business our bread and butter so as to
speak is making it really easy to accept
payments online and unfortunately one of
the realities of accepting payments
especially online
is dealing with fraud so really quickly
let me explain exactly what credit card
fraud is and why it's something that we
really care about so let's use an
example so say we have a fraudster who
steals your credit card number through
some kind of data breach so a good
example might be the big target one from
you know five six years ago where a ton
of credit card numbers were leaked so
now has your credit card number let's
say he buys an expensive watch online
something that costs a few thousand
dollars using this dollar card
transaction goes through he's really
happy he then resells this item for less
than list price on Craigslist or
somewhere that isn't easily traceable
and then a couple days later you go
online you're like I did not buy a
$3,000 watch what's going on and then
you tell your bank hey this wasn't me
and you initiate what's called a dispute
or a chargeback and this is a really
tiny picture but you might have seen a
button like that on your bank login
online that says dispute of charge so at
the end of the day let's say I dispute
this charge for this watch I didn't buy
if my bank looks into it and decides yes
this actually was fraud will I did not
buy this watch it's the merchant who
sold this watch the fraudster who's on
the hook
for the cost of fraud and the cost of
fraud literally is the value of the item
plus a certain amount of dispute fees
and globally merchants targeted by
fraudsters can end up losing a lot of
money especially if they don't have a
lot of checks and balances in place and
this is a lot of money like in 2018 it's
estimated to add up
20 billion dollars in losses for
merchants across the world due to fraud
so at stripe we've noticed that there
are three challenges in particular
surrounding credit card fraud and how
our merchants deal with it
so first is fraud is kind of a broad
term and it's not always easy for
everyone to agree on what it means so
the example I presented where someone
stole your credit card number and bought
something it's pretty obviously fraud
but there is some more like gray or sort
of cases so there's has anyone heard of
friendly fraud so when I buy something
and I like legitimately bought the thing
but then the statement that appears on
my credit card it has some weird name
and I don't recognize it and so then I'm
like dispute because you don't remember
it doesn't look like the name of the
store and so that's called friendly
fraud another example is like
subscriptions fraud where you keep
signing up free trials of blue apron or
something and then canceling out for a
month so depending on who you talk to
they might consider all of these frauds
some of these fraud secondly no matter
how you define fraud very very few
charges are actually fraud like the bulk
of people making transactions online are
legitimate customers doing so in good
faith and thirdly merchants tend to have
a very strong emotional reaction to
fraud like they tend to feel personally
spurned when they have to deal with
fraud they don't always evaluate the
actual financial impact of fraud mostly
because you know people sometimes let
emotions get in the way of their
judgment and you don't want people to
sort of it's common for people to have a
knee-jerk reaction where they're like
okay I like experienced fraud one time
I'm just gonna block every single
transaction but that's not always a
great thing to do so how did we
translate these challenges into machine
learning problems first one is it's not
always easy to agree on what fraud means
you need to figure out some way to
actually set up labels for your data so
you can train your model on what fraud
means
secondly most charges are not frog no
matter how you define fraud there's
massive class imbalance in production
data and thirdly since most merchants
aren't great at evaluating the objective
business impact of fraud we need to have
like effective model evaluation
techniques in production to ensure that
our models are actually doing what we're
optimizing them to prevent and we're not
just using people's emotional reactions
as a way to measure how effective our
models are so over the shock I'm kind of
gonna dive into each of these three
areas and talk about some of the things
we did
so first labeling data so when you're
choosing labels for your data our model
it's a binary classifier it sees our
transaction come in and needs to decide
is this fraud or is this not fraud and
importantly I hinted at having
production evaluation techniques one of
the baseline criteria for your labels is
you need to be able to obtain what those
labels mean in production like this
sounds intuitive but it's something that
you could forget if you're kind of like
in the nitty gritty and just doing a lot
of like internal testing and so at
stripe this additionally means that
labels should mean the same thing across
all the merchants who use stripe like I
don't want to evaluate one models
effectiveness on one merchant
differently from the effectiveness on
another merchant because the labels
aren't the same the comparisons are kind
of meaningless so go through some
examples of things we could use as
labels so for all models all fraud
models that we train for all the stripes
merchants so the watch example where
someone stole your card and then the
customer filed a charge back with the
bank for that transaction that's pretty
cut and dry it means fraud no matter who
the merchant is no matter who the bank
is because you literally say the reason
for your charge back is fraud similarly
there's this concept called an issue of
fraud record that
card networks and banks can send us an
example is Visa has this thing called a
TC 40 and that's basically like the card
network uses charge and they're like we
think based on all the information we
have that this charge has a certain
probability of being fraud and we found
that whenever we receive one of these
the likelihood of the charge actually
being disputed as fraud from the bank is
very high and so we've decided that this
is also a good global indicator of fraud
now let's say I have a model that is
detecting fraud for one specific
merchant so in this case if a certain
merchant tells us this one customer is a
bad actor all his interactions have been
kind of sketchy we want all charges from
this person to be fraud so this is
there's a subtle difference here if the
model is specific to that merchant I'm
probably okay incorporating that
information because that model is very
tailored to that merchant
however it's not fair for me to import
that merchants judgments on other
merchants who might not have dealt with
this customer and it might not have the
same sort of bias so yes we could use
this but we need to be careful about
which models we actually use this kind
of merchant specific labeling on and
then things are just bad ideas to use as
labels say it buy some clothes online
they don't fit I returned to the
merchant the merchant might be a bit
annoyed but that's not fraud like that
is a legitimate transaction similarly if
a merchant is just having a hard time
like dealing with customers from a
certain country and they just want to
block charges from outside the US or
from a certain country that's also not
that doesn't mean that all charges from
outside the US or from a certain country
are fraud for that merchant or for
anyone so probably not a good idea to
use that as a label and so at the end of
the day like our philosophy when it
comes to actually choosing labels is
most imporantly labels
on the audience like if you have someone
who is only interested in like kind of
friendly fraud I was talking about you
want your labels to incorporate that if
I'm only building merchants specific
models I want my MA my labels to
incorporate merchants specific judgments
and ultimately our goal at stripe with
our machine learning is to optimize for
the revenue of our merchants where we
basically want to keep the cost of fraud
down the same thing you don't to block
every single charge because then you're
not actually helping optimize revenue
you're just making them lose money
probably and so that is why we are very
conscious about using labels they're
actually correlated with true fraud
losses and not the emotional gut
reaction that is the perception of fraud
like a customer who's a serial returner
like that's not a fraud loss but as a
merchant you might not think that
they're a great customer but those are
two different things in terms of what
our model is trying to do so next class
imbalance so before we really dive into
classic balance where there's a lot of
relationships between precision recall
and FBR that I'm going to talk about and
so let's deal with some toy examples to
try and understand that so this is a
binary classifier our model produces
scores between 0 and 100 and so let's
calculate precision recall and FBR so
precision in our case is out of
everything the model said was fraud how
many of those were actually fraud and so
transaction number 6 them was the only
one the model said was fraud it is
actually fraud so precision is one
recall is out of all the fraud in the
world
how much of it did the model actually
classify correctly and so five and six
were truly fraud but the merchant only
said six was fraud so recalls one over
two just 0.5
and FBR is out of all the transactions
that were truly not fraud how many of
the merchants in Korea's sorry how many
the model incorrectly classify as fraud
there were four charges that were not
fraud the merchants said all of the
model said all of them were not fraud
we're good
FBR is zero now take the same set of
scores and outcomes but change the
models policy the block of the score is
greater than or equal to 30 instead of
90 and now suddenly all our metrics have
changed so now the model said three
things were fraud transactions four five
and six out of those only two were fraud
five and six
so now precision is 2/3 that's a 33%
reduction from our previous policy we're
position was 1 recall on the other hand
has gone up out of the two things that
were fraud the model caught both of them
great recall is one it caught all the
fraud in the world but now FBR has also
gone up because of the four transactions
that were not frog one two three four it
incorrectly said number four was fraud
so with that in mind keep that in your
back pocket it's a deal with class of
those so as I mentioned a little while
ago
very very few transactions are fraud no
matter how you choose your label and
this number is less than 1% so it's
actually like very very little relative
to the number of good transactions
however it turns out that when you are
training a model to detect fraud it's
actually it actually does a lot better
when you train it on a more balanced
data set than an imbalance data set and
so what I mean here is when you're
training a model fraud is rare right
because very few transactions are fraud
and fraud is a positive label you're
trying to predict so you want to use all
the fraud you can get your hands on but
you don't want to use like the entire
99% plus of good transactions so you
want to use like a sub
of the good transactions but all the
fraudulent transactions and that kind of
proved this like these are a couple of
precision recall curves the one on the
left was obtained by training on a very
imbalance data set which is kind of like
production data where it was less than
one percent fraud 99 percent legitimate
the one on the right which looks like a
much more normal precision recall curve
was obtained on a more balanced data set
so great why don't we just train on a
balanced data set end of story
there is one catch here though when you
train on a balanced data set you're also
validating the models performance on
that same balanced data set it's gonna
look good but your model is ultimately
deployed in production production is not
a balanced data set like just because
your model is doing well in validation
it doesn't automatically mean it's going
that same model is going to be optimal
in production so you altima to find a
class balance and training that doesn't
just look good in validation which has a
similar class balance but it also needs
to look good in production so when
you're actually evaluating models you
should make sure you evaluate them on
more imbalanced data as well to make
sure that the performance actually holds
up and that your validation ROC curve or
precision recall curve isn't misleading
so to look at why class imbalance
actually makes a difference here so
using a hypothetical model it produces a
score between zero and a hundred for
every transaction it sees and the model
is a binary classifier right so the way
we force these scores to turn into a
true/false style prediction is we pick a
threshold and we say walk if scores go
ahead and this threshold don't block if
score is less than the threshold and we
pick this threshold using our validation
data and we monitor threshold to satisfy
a certain criteria and in general
want to pick a threshold that maximizes
recall where recall is the percentage of
all the fraud in the world that the
model catches while capping FPR so why
is that a generally good goal so in
theory our model could block every
single charge it ever saw it would have
a recall of one which is awesome it
would catch all the fraud but it would
also have an FB r that is off the charts
because it's also blocking those 99
percent you know good charges and the
time is back into Hauer
the goal for our model is to optimize
revenue for merchants relative to what
they'd have without our model if we
blocked every single transaction they
would not be happy we would be losing
the money and so we want to block as
much as we can at a reasonable rate
without misclassifying too many
transactions because a false positive in
our world means a good customer who was
denied a purchase and a business does
not want you're denying good customers
purchases so if your validation set is
very imbalanced which means it has very
little fraud tons of good charges so
given the definition of what FBR is the
model let's say you have a certain FBR
ceiling your model and classify a lot of
charges wrong so it can obtain a lot of
false positives and the FBR is still
going to be low because the number of
true negatives which is one of the
things we're adding the denominator is
so high there's so many true negatives
in your data set and so what this means
is you can pick a really low threshold
between zero and a hundred you could
pick something like 10 and your model is
going to end up having very high recall
because it's gonna block everything that
scored above 10 but its precision is
gonna be terrible and that's sort of
what we see going on in this precision
recall curve where - it's the right of
the chart the recall keeps increasing
but the precision is hovering close to
zero so if your goal is to actually blow
all the fraud this is fine but you
probably don't wanna be doing it at the
expense of precision so what we
determined when we were trying to handle
class of balance
we ran a set of experiments to determine
what the optimal percentage of fraud in
the training data set should be and this
image isn't super clear but it's
basically in our OC curve and if it's
clear you can actually see that like the
blue one on top has greater AUC and so
this is basically we tried different
target rates for percentage of fraud in
your training dataset to see which one
works best and ultimately since fraud is
rare you want to use all the fraud you
have access to for training but kind of
down sample all the non fraud uniformly
so that you hit the target rate you want
so as an example let's say you have a
thousand charges out of which only ten
are fraud so 990 are not fraud and you
run some experiments and you determine
that the model you trained in which the
training data had ten percent fraud
that's the model that actually before
best when you evaluated it against
production data and so to obtain the
kind of training set that yielded
optimum performance you would keep those
ten fraudulent charges you would only
keep 90 of the non fraudulent charges
you would discard nine hundred of the
non fraudulent charges and so now your
data set for training is ten fraud
ninety nine fraud ten percent target
fraud rate in your training data
hopefully you have more than ten
positive examples to train on but as an
illustration we determined that actually
discarding the bulk of the good
transactions ended up really helping
model performance so the third issue is
production model evaluation
techniques so before I get into what
counterfactual evaluation means I wanted
to quickly highlight why this is an
important thing to do and what it's
trying to solve so for our model true
positives are fraudulent transactions
that the model said was fraud and
correctly blocked false positives are
legitimate transactions by good
customers that immoral that the model
incorrectly labeled as fraud ended up
blocking however if our model is in
production thinks of charges fraud and
it blocks it how do you actually know if
that charge was going to end up being
fraud you haven't actually let the
charge go through to see what the true
outcome is like your model has biased
the outcome by blocking the transaction
ultimately you need the transaction to
go through that the card network to see
if it's fraud or not fraud so how do you
actually know if your model got
something right like how do you know if
the charge it just blocked was going to
be fraud similarly how do you know if
the model got it wrong how do you know
that it incorrectly blocked a charge
that that was actually a legitimate
transaction so we basically need to come
up with some way the estimate true
positives and false positives in
production the Catholic precision and
recall in production this is really easy
to do in validation data because you're
training on transactions for which you
have known outcomes but this is not
straightforward to do in production
because you are biasing charge outcomes
in production by running your model so
counterfactual evaluation what does that
mean time factual evaluation is a
technique that is meant to measure what
would have happened to in our case a
transaction but in the general sense any
event in the absence of the machine
learning models intervention and the two
main reasons why we want to do this
the first as I just touched upon is you
want some way to evaluate the
performance of your model in production
tip by estimating true positives and
false positives the second one which
might not be as obvious is this is
actually how you would generate unbiased
training data from production data and
so did dive into that a little bit
so our model blocks some transactions
that it thinks are fraud and it lets all
the others that it things are not fraud
go through we can only train our model
on transactions for which we have labels
labels are fraud versus not fraud which
means we can only train our model on
transactions that the model has not
blocked because we need the transactions
to actually have outcomes and have an
outcome the transaction needs to have
not been blocked so if you don't let
your model keep blocking transactions
that it thought was fraud all the
transactions that you have outcomes for
because the model has blocked most of
the things that thought were fraud most
of the charges it allowed are actually
not hopefully not going to be fraud so
if you look at only the charges it
allowed there's not a lot of fraud left
and so what happens here is the only
fraudulent charges that you end up
seeing at this point are fraud that the
model could not detect which is why it
presumably didn't block them so now your
model is only training on the really
really hard fraud that it couldn't block
and so over time you keep training the
model on hard fraud it ends up
forgetting what easy fraud looks like
and so you need some way to actually
obtain labels for this easy fraud such
your model can keep training on them and
this is a real problem the chart on the
left was the model when it was initially
trained doing really well and the one on
the right is how the ROC curve started
looking after it started forgetting what
easy fraud look like
so how did we try to solve this so
initially our attempt number one was for
a we did a small percentage of the
transactions that the model was going to
block and we basically reversed the
block decision to allow them to go
through and so we basically had a
function to determine the probability of
allowing a charge so I don't know if you
can read but like this is a hypothetical
function where let's say your model
would block if score greater than or
equal to 60 for charges between sixty
and a hundred there's like an
increasingly smaller probability of the
charge being allowed and the motivation
was you the more risky a charge the less
likely you wanted the likelihood of a
lot of allowing it to be so that's why
you sort of set up this like inversely
proportional reversal function and so
this way your them we were consciously
letting through a small number of the
normal frog to obtain true outcomes and
that way we could actually see how the
model was doing and so when we wanted to
evaluate how the model was doing we
would look at the transaction that were
led by the model so this includes
transactions that the model scored low
which is why they were allowed as well
as some of the higher risk transactions
that were kind of probabilistic ly
reversed and then when we were
evaluating and training we would wait
each of these allowed transactions by
one over PLL so if your score was less
than the block threshold this weight
would be 1 because pilau is 1 if you're
under the block threshold and if you
were one of those risky charges that was
reversed you know we would go up based
on what your reversal probability was
and then we would incorporate these
weights and as anyone who's used
scikit-learn is familiar you can very
easily incorporate weights into
precision and recall calculations and so
just to illustrate what this looked like
with something
samples let's say your model by default
would block it was the score was greater
than or equal to 80
so precision it block transactions three
and four but if you have to look at the
outcome column three was not fraud four
was fraud and so now when you're
incorporating the weight precision is 10
over 10 plus 5 which is two-thirds
recall is 2 & 4 were fraud and the model
only caught transaction for not
transaction - but transaction 2 had a
weight of 1 so recall is now 10 over 11
which is 0.9 1 so this sounds great but
we found some issues with this method so
first was when you have the system of
weights that can drastically differ
based on the probability of reversal
there's a lot of variance in what those
weights actually end up being and this
variance caused a lot of noise when we
were estimating precision and recall by
you incorporating the weights in how we
estimated those metrics so a single high
weight transaction if it was
misclassified could significantly skew
the estimates that we had if you had a
data set that isn't particularly Friday
and let's say you had a transaction for
which P allow was point 0 1 the
transaction goes through whatever it was
you know through the block it got it
wrong that that transactions are being
not fraud you now have this weight of a
hundred which if it was like one of five
transactions that were reversed the
weight of a hundred it actually like
ended up making a big difference when we
were calculating metrics secondly there
were like challenges around calculating
the P allow in the propensity function
so that propensity function was under
the assumption that events if that was
being fed we're all independent
and the function was been to
deterministically generate the P allow
for any event that it was fed and so how
should we define an independent event is
that a user session where you could make
multiple charges was that each
individual transaction someone tried to
make but then how do you deal with
retries where the first time someone
missed types their credit card
information and then they try again or
like their internet went down and then
they try again like we weren't entirely
confident about the independence
assumption that we made when we designed
that function and that just made us not
have confidence in the estimations we
were actually getting so our second
attempt for a small percentage of
transactions we score a transaction
using the model get a score between zero
and hundred just like always regardless
of what the score is you allow that
transaction so here you can actually see
this is an example of how it would look
where the X is 10% so for 10% of charges
no matter what the score is you would
allow those Tartus and so as always if
your score is below the block threshold
you were gonna get allowed anyway but
now if your scores between 60 and 100
which is the region we would be blocking
in each of those charges now has a
uniform likelihood 10% of reversal and
so if you consider this X percent the
whole back group all the transactions in
the whole back group get operated by one
or a PLL which would be one over point
one ten and you would use these weights
in training and evaluation and so why
does this work better we now have no
variance in our weights our weights are
all the same and because this whole back
group is a uniform sample of all
production data it's true precision and
recall we aren't kind of probably
changing how much a charge should impact
Enrico liked this whole bout group is a
representative sample of all
transactions we see and so you can kind
of scale up or down the estimate to
infer how it would be for your entire
transaction volume and ultimately the
big takeaway for us was getting rid of
the variance in our estimator function
gave us much more confidence in what the
actual estimates match and then when we
incorporated these weights and training
turns out it didn't actually make a big
difference compared to the old
probabilistic propensity function so
ultimately what were our takeaways here
the first is the appropriate label to
use for your data depends on what you're
optimizing for in our case we wanted to
optimize to prevent fraud losses but if
you were actually building a model to
optimize for emotional impact or fraud
you might want different labels so keep
that in mind and it also varies
depending on who you're trying to solve
the problem for so if you have merchants
specific labeling information don't try
to like use that for other people you
keep it scoped to the context of your
model second aiming for a constant
target rate of the positive class in the
training data resulted in better
long-term class balance and model
performance so this was keeping the
percentage of fraud in the data set
constant when training note that this is
subtly different from having a fixed
down sampling rate for the negative
class because if you're a training data
volume changes with time that leads to
variance in the percentage of the data
that you're positive class represents
and finally you want a production model
evaluations technique that works for you
that generates training data for you and
that most importantly you trust with
your estimates thank you for listening I
hope you found this interesting
thank you that's great talk so my
question is on the labels I guess so you
talked about friendly fraud but that
seems like that would legitimately bias
your entire model so if somebody was
just really bad at picking the string
that shows up in the credit card thing
you would think that that merchant is
more susceptible to fraud and it would
kind of feed on itself because every
time a transaction would get flagged it
would then he continued to kind of end
up in this loop is there any handling
for something like that so I think in
that case you would want a model that
wasn't trained on a per transaction
basis probably on a per person basis
almost where virtue yeah yeah well
friendly fraud is more like the actual
the customer orders something and they
don't recognize a recognize that it's on
their statement right and so their
purchasing patterns actually looked very
normal but you know they're just bad at
remembering that they ordered things or
something like that so with in front for
the case of friendly fraud specifically
I would actually argue that you're
trying to find you're trying to
determine if the person making that
transaction is likely to forget that
they made it which is what makes it
friendly fraud right and so in that case
you would probably not want a model that
ran on individual transactions using
transaction level features you sort of
want like person level features supposed
to say but that merchants getting double
hit because the models biasing saying
that they're more susceptible to fraud
and they get the charge back to sorry so
are you is your concern basically you
have this retraining you yeah it seems
like the more fraudulent things that
show up the more likely it is to get
flagged the more likely it is to get
flagged next time so you don't this is
now getting like feature engineering
sort of territory where you don't want
to have features that are unfairly
biasing like
emerging gets hit with a fraud attack if
all your features had to do with like
how much fraud has this merchant
historically seen or even like how much
fraud has this credit card seen or where
if someone stole your credit card and
made some transactions you're you don't
want that to be biasing you for future
transactions that you make right so yeah
I think that that's instead of a
labeling issue that is more like you
need features that are not going to bias
future evaluations and that's a hard
problem to solve okay thank you thank
you for your talk
so you subsampled your data to try and
deal with this class and balance issue
I'm curious if you tried reweighed in
your samples so that you could use all
your data but then kind of deal with the
class and balance issue and what
happened with that so we did try doing
that and ultimately subsampling uses
less computational power when you can
discard some amount of data and if you
can spend less on computing while still
maintaining model performance
that's not savings great thanks
Thanks so you mentioned that in the
current system just with the probability
of 10% the transaction is allowed
doesn't that mean that anyone who wants
to commit fraud just has to try 10 times
not necessarily depends on how we're
determining independent events
gotcha so you said it might be per user
session so couldn't they just start ten
sessions it's not necessarily obvious
how we calculate user session okay yeah
gotcha
I mean do you mind if a follow-up you
mentioned also that for Justin you want
to minimize the revenue that's lost as a
result of fraud what's like the average
amount lost per false positive versus
the vs. like two negatives as in real
fraud versus this fake fraud that is
really hard to answer because it depends
on what each merchant wants to optimize
for so like if you're some people are
really really risk-averse they're like I
don't want to deal with any fraud I
don't care if you block 50 additional
transactions because I'm so risk-averse
like they're actually choosing to forgo
like money from true negatives because
they're so scared of false positives on
the other hand if you're a business with
sort of higher profit margins you can
afford to take the hit for like
borderline fraud cases because you don't
care about a few false positives in
amidst all the true negatives so I don't
have like a hard number to give you
because it depends on how much your
average transaction is right like the
watch merchant I use as an example has a
much higher average transaction volume
than someone like lyft where you're
right is probably 20 bucks so totally
depends on that thank you
so we're few minutes beyond our time
limit if you guys have any questions
we'll take them offline
thank you all for coming